Хрустка скоринка, духмяний м’якуш. У 70-их роках цей "житній домашній хліб" за спецрецептом випікали для радянських керівників.
Тепер його готують до столу всіх киян на цьому підприємстві в Броварах.
Колись ця пекарня була державним підприємством і виготовляла 3-4 сорти хліба в ось таких майже руїнах.
Тепер тут печуть щодня 50 сортів хліба та іншої здоби.
Київський пекарний дім" за кілька років зміг стати конкурентоспроможним завдяки модернізації виробництва й енергоефективним технологіям.
Підприємство входить до Всеукраїнської асоціації пекарів. В асоціації заявляють, що її члени працюють за моделлю
енергоефективного та дружнього для довкілля бізнесу, який постійно дбає про зменшення енерговитрат.
У першу чергу це економія енергоресурсів - газу. Були замінені пальники на більш сучасні.
Це економія до 20% споживання газу, також на опаленні підприємства. На кожній ділянці були проведені певні роботи.
Але ми тільки на початку шляху і продовжуємо цей напрямок.
Енергозберігальні лампи, нові пальники котлів, горілки печей, утеплення корпусів, нові металопластикові вікна.
Такий алгоритм енергоефективних змін у пекарні в Броварах розробили на основі деталізованого енергоаудиту,
який для підприємства провели експерти Німецького товариства міжнародного співробітництва GIZ.
Товариство працює в Україні з 2009 року за дорученням німецького уряду і допомагає уряду України з втіленням різних реформ,
зокрема в галузі енергозбереження та енергоефективності.
Подібний детальний план енергозаощадження і водночас зниження викидів СО2 німецькі експерти склАли і для інших українських пекарень,
зацікавлених у використанні німецького досвіду з енергоефективності.
GIZ консультує українські підприємства щодо енергозбереження з 2017 року.
Крім того, спонукає їх об'єднуватися в так звані мережі енергоефективності, члени яких самі беруть на себе зобов’язання
стати "більш дружніми до довкілля".
Одна з перших таких мереж була створена у Львові в 2018-тому.
11 промислових підприємств за 2 роки змогли добитися зменшення споживання електроенергії на 9700 мегават-годин
і скорочення викидів СО2 на 3300  тонн.
Цей проєкт в GIZ вважають вельми успішним. Він об’єднав уже близько сотні підприємств з різних галузей.
Результатом консультацій підприємців-партнерів проекту зі створення мереж енергоефективності стало те,
що вони лише за перші 6 місяців змогли втілити понад 60 різних заходів, що дало можливість зекономити 7616 мегават-годин на рік.
Це успіх моделі енергоефективних мереж. І підприємці хочуть далі зменшувати споживання енергії - до 15800 мегават-годин на рік.
Це значить на 5 з половиною тонн викидів СО2 на рік менше.
Застаріла інфраструктура, відсутність логістики енергоефективності і в приватному, і в державному секторі економіки.
За висновками GIZ, Україна має величезний потенціал для енергозбереження - у грошовому вимірі до мільярда євро на рік.
За висновками експертів ще однієї німецької установи, яка допомагає Україні за дорученням уряду ФРН - Кредитної установи для відбудови KfW,
через погану енергоефективність Україна втрачає до 44 відсотків теплової та електроенергії.
Приміром, за підрахунками KfW, щорічні втрати енергії тільки на передавальних електромережах становлять  6000 гігават-годин.
Заходи з енергоефективності допомогли б тільки на цьому зекономити зекономити до 3 відсотків виробленої електроенергії на рік.
За висновками німців, це дало б можливість зупинити роботу цsлої АЕС. KfW співпрацює з урядом України вже майже понад 15 років.
За цей час установа підтримала інвестиціями багато проєктів: модернізація підстанцій, енергоефективне оновлення громадських будівель
та громадського транспорту в Харкові, Житомирі і Запоріжжі, впровадження енергоефективних технологій в бізнесі.
Лише за останні півтора року в модернізацію енергетичного сектору України обсяг інвестицій від KfW разом з іншими партнерами України -
такими, як Світовий банк, Європейський інвестиційний банк - склав понад 50 мільйонів євро.
Кредитування "зелених" проєктів є пріоритетом для багатьох потужних міжнародних банків.
Приміром, Європейський банк реконструкції та розвитку активний у цій площині в Україні ще з 2006 року.
Ми інвестували приблизно 4 мільярди євро в понад 230 проектів в Україні за ці роки.
Це третина від загального обсягу фінансування ЄБРР загалом в економіку України.
За розрахунками наших фахівців, якщо взяти сумарно зменшення викидів вуглецю в атмосферу від реалізації цих проектів, то це еквівалентно викидам,
що спричиняють 8 мільйонів автомобілів на рік.
За фінансової підтримки ЄБРР в Україні нещодавно з'явився перший "зелений супермаркет". Тут усе - за передовими енергоефективними технологіями.
Сонячні панелі зменшують витрати на електроенергію на 650000 гривень на рік. Енергія землі з геотермальної станції
дозволяє майже повністю відмовитися від центрального опалення і електропостачання для охолодження холодильників.
Візочки нашого супермаркету на чверть виготовлені з переробленого пластику з рибальських сіток та мотузок,
які становлять 27 відсотків від забруднення всіх океанів.
Загальний обсяг інвестицій ЄБРР у розширення цієї торгівельної мережі  становить майже 60 мільйонів доларів.
На заходи з енергоефективності банк виділив "Сільпо" додатковий грант на суму 300000 доларів.
Подібними грантами банк мотивує підприємців робити свій бізнес більше енергоефективним.
У "зеленому" супермаркеті працює також станція ресайклінгу.
Покупці здають пляшки, пластик, папір і накопичують бали, які потім можуть обміняти на товари.
Ідея станції полягає в тому, аби наші гості могли принести свою вторсировину для того, щоб ми могли її переробити. Це робиться для поліпшення екології.
Одна з умов отримання "зелених" кредитів або грантів - підприємці мають не лише робити свій бізнес сприятливішим до довкілля,
але й заохочувати населення ставати екологічно свідомішими.
Мені ця ідея подобається. Я поки не дійшла до системного сортування сміття. Але до цього рухаюся.
Мені зручно, що супермаркет поряд з домом. І я можу в будь-який момент прийти і викинути чітко пластик до пластику, скло до скла.
Якщо кожен магазин буде використовувати такі технології, то, думаю, ми скоро дійдемо до високого рівня.
Екологічність поволі стає трендом в українському бізнесі.
Пекарня в Броварах, як і інші члени Всеукраїнської асоціації пекарів, ставлять перед собою амбітну мету - стати на 85% енергоефективнішими вже через рік.
У це інвестували вже понад два з половиною мільйони гривень власних коштів.
Економічний ефект – помітне зниження споживання газу, тепла та струму.
Це дасть їм можливість не підвищувати ціни на хліб попри зростання вартості енергоресурсів.
Наступний крок - встановлення станції з переробки тепла, яке утворюються від роботи печей і просто викидається в повітря.
Ми менше будемо витрачати газу на підігрів води, пару, на технологічні і побутові цілі. Усе це - суттєва економія.
Пекарі хочуть вивчити умови співпраці з іншими європейськими фінансовими інституціями, які кредитують "зелені" проєкти.
Претендувати на "зелені" кредити можуть будь-які компанії, які готові працювати енергоефективно.
У заявці на кредит має бути чітко прописаний план запланованих заходів, а також детальне обґрунтування позитивного ефекту для довкілля.
Крім того, підприємства мають  бути готовими до постійного контролю з боку європейських кредиторів чи їхніх партнерів.
Ринок такого кредитування буде зростати. Адже Україна взяла на себе зобов’Язання виконувати Сталі цілі розвитку ООН
щодо ощадливого енергоспоживання і розробила Національний план заходів, для реалізації якого потрібно щонайменше 43 мільярди євро інвестицій.